welcome to another famous friday i
believe that the fastest way to
accomplish any goal is to model success
find someone who's already gone out and
achieve the goal that you want to
accomplish
model what worked for them and apply it
to your business so today we're going to
learn from phil knight
phil knight is the founder of a company
called nike
now when he started this business it was
just an idea
he was assigned he was a university
student he was assigned with a project
and the project was come up with a
business idea
in a market that you know and create a
report on it
write a little business plan for it and
he was a track runner he loved running
and so he thought
i'm gonna make a business plan around
shoes
adidas had a stranglehold on the market
and he figured there was an
opportunity to go to japan and get some
high quality shoes that are made at a
low cost and import them into the united
states
and that was the crux of his business
plan and he submitted it as part of his
course
and when he graduated he felt like you
know that was a really good idea
maybe i can do this maybe i could be an
entrepreneur
and he decided to act on his business
plan
not just let that sit as something that
was marked and gritted and helped him
graduate and he got whatever mark he got
on it but
this could actually be something that i
do in my life
and he didn't have the connections he
didn't have the experience he wasn't a
businessman he didn't have a lot of
capital resources but he decided
he was going to take it upon himself to
try this business idea
and so he flew to japan and he started
meeting with companies and he started
lining up potential deals
and he started working with potential
suppliers and he started
nike and nike began with
500 from him and 500 from his partner
bill bowerman
and that was the start of nike they paid
35 to a local university student to help
them design
their logo which was the nike swoosh and
they were in business
this is a really important lesson
because how many of you have designed a
business plan
have written it down or come up with
something in your head but then you
don't act on
and you may tell yourself a story like i
don't have the experience i don't have
the connections i don't have
the contacts you know i don't know what
i'm doing i can never get this thing off
the ground
if you want to start your business then
you need to start
you need to believe in yourself you
gotta stop daydreaming
stop just writing business plans stop
thinking about
notes of what you're gonna do and
actually start
and start small it doesn't have to cost
you a lot of money
start small start talking to customers
start making some connections
start getting some experience and every
day move one step closer
to getting your goal actually happen
and if you do that then you might build
the next night
believe you guys like this video you
want to see more you can subscribe to
the channel by clicking below
thank you so much i'll see you soon
every week i share my best information
to help you
fuel your business forward in my
newsletter
check it out below hi i'm jason j ross
fonseca of riseonline.com
and i want to say evan carmichael's
newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring and it's the only
newsletter i prioritize and look forward
to
period